you might remember that a few months ago
was it we interviewed Scott Adams the
creator of Dilbert
I received an e-mail early this morning
inquiring about another interview
possibility with Scott Adams take a
listen to this hi I was wondering if
you're ever going to interview the
Dilbert creator of Scott Adams again the
interviewer I saw was looks like it was
from December and it must have mistaken
I believe you said something in there
that there was going to be a part to you
perhaps that was just provided to
members but I think it would be
interesting now that some time has
passed to see what he has to say about a
few things so I was just wondering if I
if there's another interview and the
works or if there ever could be Thanks
I'm open to interviewing Scott Adams
again I don't know if the audience wants
me to I have been following I follow him
on Twitter we follow each other on
Twitter and he used to be all about it's
not Trump policy that I'm supporting but
his persuasion skills and the way that
he campaigned are really indicative of a
brilliant and genius communicator he now
is just saying Trump's policy is amazing
right so if you look at his recent
tweets over the last couple of days
Scott Adams now seems to be a genuine
advocate of of what Donald Trump has
done so I don't know how you really
interview somebody like that you know so
I'm open to hearing from the audience
about whether you want me to interview
Dilbert creator Scott Adams again I
don't know that he would agree he seems
generally open to interviews and and I
think people he's spoken to before he
would sort of be amenable to being
interviewed by again but I don't know
that the audience wants me to interview
Scott Adams again and he does seem to
have completely jumped the shark as far
as his views go at this point and you
know I would say that to him directly I
was not this is not something I'm
willing to say now but not if I talk to
the guy let me know if you want him back
on the program on the bonus show today
an update about the Morgan Freeman
sexual assault allegations dolphin
happiness is being measured by French
scientists and Senate Democrats are
looking to get some political traction
with gas prices and that's something
I've talked about for years and I want
to
dress all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show become a member at
join pakman.com and get instant access
to the bonus show you can also get
accessed by becoming a patreon patron
thanks for watching thanks for listening
we will talk to you on the bonus show